big news today guys I'm driving home
from a screening of the World's End for
view for that coming very soon and I get
a text Ben Affleck is the new Batman I
guess it was bound to happen after a
while I mean he was the bomb and
phantoms and as I've told you guys in
the past my drive to and from screenings
are about 40 minutes each way and so I
had some time to think about it as I
went home from the movie and this is
what I have concluded let's say that
back in 2004 they announced that Ben
Affleck would be the new Batman and
Christopher Nolan's Batman Begins right
at that time I would say wow that is the
worst idea I have ever heard in my life
what a horrible piece of crap actor why
are they doing this
daredevil flopped it wasn't very good
why are they doing this
because I was somebody who was actually
really into daredevil when it first came
out I was hoping it was gonna be really
good I mean look I still have the
daredevil novelization from when I was a
kid I was really into this movie and it
disappointed me in a lot of ways but I
will say this I don't really think it
was Ben Affleck in the movie that was
essentially the problem it really was
Mark Steven Johnson the director who's
gone on to do absolutely nothing of
merit that being said if I had heard
that news back then and it was Batman
for that film I wouldn't been pretty mad
because I knew that they were trying to
make a really serious version of Batman
and I would have just looked at that and
been disappointed however since then Ben
Affleck has really turned his career
around he's become a terrific director
and he's done nothing but good
performances ever since then he was
great in the state of play he was good
in Hollywood land for him to turn around
his career from being the guy who was
dating Jennifer Lopez and starring in
movies like pay cheque and daredevil to
Best Picture winner Ben Affleck now that
is impressive and what role was that
that started his career turning around
he played the actor George Reeves who
was Superman in the film Hollywood land
the role that helped him turn his film
career around was portraying the actor
who portrayed Superman now that is
interesting
so like I said if I had heard that
announcement back then I would have been
really really upset
hearing it today I sat there in my car I
drove over 40 minutes and I came to the
conclusion that
actually don't mind that idea and I'll
tell you why first off everyone always
hates everything that is ever announced
ever when they announced that Heath
Ledger was gonna be the Joker everyone
was like really the guy from 10 Things I
Hate About You great nice job he's gonna
be the most iconic Batman villain ever
great that's wonderful and then the Dark
Knight happened and everyone was
revealed to be an idiot and tons of
people are saying Christian Bale was
gonna be terrible in the movie and there
are still people who think he is what
but he do I don't care he was awesome
and I love the map my point is that
whenever anything is ever announced in
the fanboy realm of the entertainment
field everyone always hates it I got to
see his performance first and then I'll
let you know how I feel about it
in regards to what I think he can do
because that's all I can really do is
speculate at this point I think he's
gonna do a good job and I'll tell you
why he has publicly admitted that
daredevil really damaged his career he
took it up the butt with that movie he
really did for him to say you know what
I just won Best Picture
I've completely turned my career around
and now I'm gonna take another giant
mainstream role because I'm finally at
that point where I've turned my career
around I'm gonna take another huge
mainstream role in a movie that I'm not
directing that I don't have anything to
do with except I am gonna play Batman
he's got to be thinking this script is
good I've got an idea of how I can do
this and we're gonna do it right he's
experienced extreme failure before
playing a comic-book superhero
experiencing failure is the best way to
then create success because you know
what you did wrong and now you can do it
right that is the entire essence of
Batman he experiences complete failure
in his life in every way and then he
experiences Redemption through Batman so
in a way Ben Affleck his Batman in real
life he actually is essentially Batman
without the costume he doesn't fight
crime and you know what I mean but I am
skeptical of course because it's Ben
Affleck and he's a bigger name than I
thought it would be I was kind of hoping
for Josh Brolin but that didn't seem to
work out I will say that Ben Affleck has
like a mole right here that might be
kind of annoying as Batman they might
have to do something about that
but of course Christian Bale has
like right there look at me deliberating
about a mole whatever they'll extend the
bat mask up like this far it'll be like
this much of his faces to cover up that
mole that kind of stuff matters
it does looking all honesty I'm just
kind of excited about the fact that I
have something to say about the
character of Batman and that he's cast
in some way I am a big fan of Ben
Affleck I honestly am I think he's a
great director and I think he's a very
good actor he turned his career around
and I'm very optimistic about what he
can do as the character I'm not gonna
say that it's gonna be horrible until I
see it this movie has what I think it
should have a director is passionate
about the source material a producer
who's passionate about the source
material a whole bunch of people who are
passionate about the source material man
if steel was a lot of fun and I enjoyed
it and I think the filmmakers can learn
from any mistakes that remain the first
one and make this next one even better I
can understand someone thinking it's a
terrible idea don't get me wrong but I'm
gonna remain optimistic I want to see
those first set photos their first
official photos of him in the costume I
want to see all those comments or
everyone's saying how shitty it looks
and who knows maybe they'll be
absolutely right but I want to give him
a chance because at this point I think
he's proven that he can make good
entertainment and I hope he does the
same thing with Batman I was still
hoping for Josh Brolin though that's
okay so guys what are your thoughts in
this casting news I'm sure a lot of
people hate it
I've already read some comments of
people that think it's a great idea I
haven't read that one calm yet that's
like oh my gosh yay finally better like
it doesn't really seem like anyone is at
that level but I gotta be honest I'm
trusting the guy and I hope he does a
good job thanks as always very much for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]